i knew much of the great ostanako the
warrior and orator of the cherokee
he was always the guest of my father on
his journeys to and from williamsburg i
was in his camp when he made his great
farewell oration to his people the
evening before he departed for england
the moon was in full splendor and to her
he seemed to address himself in his
prayers for his own safety on the voyage
and that of his people during his
absence
his sounding voice distinct articulation
animated action and the solemn silence
of his people at their several fires
filled me with awe and veneration
although i did not understand a single
word he uttered
a few days before they were to depart
for their own country mr horox invited
ostanako and myself to sup with him at
the college
where amongst other curiosities he
showed him the picture of his present
majesty
the chief viewed it a long time with
particular attention when turning to me
long he said i have wished to see the
king my father this is his resemblance
but i am determined to see him myself
i am now near the sea and never will
depart from it till i have obtained my
desires
he asked the governor the next day who
though he had first refused on
ostanako's insisting so strongly upon it
gave his consent he then desired as i
had been with him so long that i might
accompany him to england this i was to
do with my own expense but the governor
told me he would recommend me to the
minister of state which he did in as
strong terms as i could desire
i was then upon the point of entering
into a very advantageous commerce which
i quit to please the indians
i prepared everything necessary for my
voyage but this was not my only expense
the indians having no money expect the
person who travels with them to treat
them with whatever they take a fancy to
so we set out for hampton about the
beginning of may where we were to embark
but contrary winds and other delays
[ __ ] us till the 15th during which
time it generally cost me between 15 and
20 shillings per day
we had very fine weather during the
whole voyage yet both the indians and
myself were seasick all the way who had
the misfortune here to lose the
interpreter shori which was much
regretted by us all but especially by
the indians as he was a thorough master
of their language he had lingered some
time into consumption caught in a small
river for being drunk his indian spouse
plunged him in to sober him but was
unable to draw him out
on the 16th of june we arrived at
plymouth
while in the boat that took us to shore
osternaco painted in a very frightful
manner sung a solemn dirge with very
loud voice to return god thanks for his
safe arrival
the loudness and uncouthness of his
singing and the oddity of his person
drew a vast crowd of boats filled with
spectators from all the ships in the
harbour and the landing place was so
thronged that it was almost impossible
to get to the inn where we took post
for london
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
question what is the oldest city in the
united states is it a saint augustine
florida b plymouth massachusetts or c
old san juan puerto rico
yes of course the answer is none of them
as native american cities were there
long before and so take a dive into
early american history with my
recommendation on magellan this week
witch hunt in salem it's a great
docu-drama that really puts you into the
shoes of early settlers and the paranoia
and fear that grow amongst them i'm
hoping to do a video on salem soon and
this was a great primer and of course
magellan has more than 3000 other
documentaries to check out too and this
christmas voices of the past viewers can
take advantage of a special holiday
offer buy one get one free gift cards
for an annual membership by clicking on
the link in the description
thanks
[Music]
we stopped at exeter where the indians
were shown the cathedral but contrary to
my expectations were as little struck as
if they had been natives of the place
they were much better pleased the next
day with lord pembroke's seat at wilton
till they saw the statue of hercules
with his club uplifted which they
thought so dreadful that they begged
immediately to be gone
we arrived the next day in london
captain blake waited on lord egremont to
acquaint him with our arrival
we were immediately sent for and after
some few questions dismissed i however
took this opportunity of flipping my
letter of recommendation into his
lordship's hands which he read and
assured me he would show it to the king
that day telling me to let the indians
or myself want for nothing
my first care was to equip the indians
so i asked mr kakanthropus to order all
after the mode of their own country
the cherokees are of a middle stature of
an olive color though generally painted
and their skin stained with gunpowder
pricked into it in very pretty figures
the hair of their head is shaved except
a patch on the hinder part of the head
about twice the bigness of a crown piece
which is ornamented with beads feathers
wampum stained deer's hair and such like
baubles
the ears are slit and stretched to an
enormous size putting the person who
undergoes the operation in incredible
pain
the uncommon appearance of the cherokees
began to draw after them great crowds of
people of all ranks at which they were
so much displeased that home became
irksome to them and they were forever
telling me to take them to some public
diversion
their favorite was sadler's wells the
activity of the performers and the
machinery of the pantomime agreeing best
with their notions of diversions
but they were better pleased with
vauxhall and though it was always
against my inclination i accompanied
them there on account of the
ungovernable curiosity of the people who
often intruded on them and induced them
to drink more than sufficient
once in particular one of the young
indians got extremely intoxicated and
committed several irregularities that
ought rather to be attributed to those
that entice them than to the simple
indians who drank only to please them
though they are very hardy bearing heat
cold hunger and thirst in a surprising
manner no people are given to more
excess in eating and drinking when it is
conveniently in their power the follies
nay mischief they commit when inebriated
are entirely laid to the liquor and no
one will revenge any injury murder
accepted received from one who is no
more himself
they are not less addicted to gaming
than drinking and will even lose the
shirt off their back rather than give
over play when luck runs against them
i cannot indeed cite sobriety as their
characteristic but this i can say these
excesses never happened in the house we
stayed a bottle of wine a bowl of punch
and a little cider being the ordinary
consumption of the three indians sumter
and myself and as we were seldom at home
it could not put the nation to a great
expense
so if the bills given in for these
articles were to the greatest degree
excessive
let them that charge them answer who
consumed them i only know that no more
was ever drank by us
unfortunately this was not the only
thing laid to my charge
i was accused of receiving money for
admission to see the indians
it was a long time before i knew
anything of these money-taking schemes
the following accident was what brought
it to light
our man sumter who had contracted some
genteel acquaintance some of whom he was
bringing to see the indians was stopped
by the servant who refused to admit them
without money
sampter received that affront from an
insolent servant but not being able to
bear the insult he took a warrior's
satisfaction and knocked him down
a blunt virginian soldier could not know
the laws of england as little can he
bear an insult from so mean a quarter
soon after these disturbances orders
were given by lord aggramont that no
person whatever should be admitted
without an order from himself or mr wood
under secretary of state
but instead of the throngs decreasing by
this order they rather increased and i
really believe few persons have more
friends than mr wood
they even pressed into the indians
dressing room which gave them the
highest disgust these people having a
particular aversion to being stared at
while dressing or eating that was so
disgusted that they grew extremely shy
of being seen so that i had the greatest
difficulty in procuring people aside of
them
[Music]
several days passed before i had any
further orders the indians became
extremely anxious to see the king
what is the reason said they that we are
not admitted to see the great king our
father after coming so far for the
purpose
i was obliged to reply that his majesty
was indisposed and could not be waited
on till perfectly recovered which in
some measure pacified them
they are extremely proud despising the
lower class of europeans and in some
athletic diversions i once was present
at they refuse to match or hold
conference with any but officers
they seldom turn their eyes on the
person they speak of or address
themselves to and always suspicious when
people's eyes are fixed upon them
they speak so low except in council that
they are often obliged to repeat what
they were saying yet should a person
talk to any of them above their common
pitch they would immediately ask him if
he thought they were deaf
some time before they left england they
were admitted finally to a conference
with his majesty at st james's
ostanako's speech on that occasion
contained nothing more than
protestations of friendship and faithful
alliance
to which an answer was afterwards given
in writing to be interpreted in their
own country as i was not conversant
enough in their language to translate it
though i understood whatever they said
especially the speech which i gave word
for word to his majesty as surey had
likewise explained it before his death
except the last part which indeed was so
much in my favor that i was obliged to
suppress it
they were struck with the youth person
and grandeur of his majesty and
conceived as great an opinion of his
affability as of his power
finding ostanaco preparing his pipe to
smoke with his majesty according to the
indian custom of declaring friendship i
told him he must neither offer to shake
hands or smoke with the king as it was
an honor for the greatest of our nation
to just kiss his hand
you are in the right he told me for he
commands over all next to the man above
and nobody is his equal
their ideas were likewise greatly
increased by the number of ships in the
river and the warren at woolwich which i
did not fail to set out to the greatest
advantage intimating that our sovereign
had many such ports and arsenals around
the kingdom
[Music]
some days before the indians set out on
their return to their own country lord
egremont sent for me and informed me
that the indians were to be landed at
charles town
but this was so contrary to their
inclination that osternaco positively
declared that unless he was to land in
virginia he would not stir a step from
london
i informed his lordship that it was
entirely out of my power to accompany
them there having scarce five shillings
remaining out of the 130 pounds i'd
received the best part of which i laid
out for the indians use that i was ready
to obey his lordship if he would please
order me wherewith to defray my expenses
my lord replied that no more could be
advanced that if i refuse to accompany
them others must be found that would
had i really had the money i should not
have troubled the government or deserted
the indians but to be landed in a
strange country without money and far
from my friends
did not seem very eligible
so the indians soon re-embarked in the
same vessel that brought them and left
england about the 25th of august so that
i was now entirely at my own expense
without money
or friends